talks of course the talks are concerned
with uh smooth analysis or online
algorithms and i think maybe in in one
or two cases both
uh the first talk about prefix
discrepancy is concerned with uh
improving uh results of prior results
about prefix discrepancy in in the
setting of smooth analysis and it also
generalizes the problem from what could
be regarded as a single path to to to
dags and to set systems the next talk is
is about a smooth analysis of
sub-modular maximization and its kind of
take-home is that is that greed is still
good in that setting where the the
smoothing is with respect to the the
budget involved
the greedy algorithm still works but the
approximation ratios can be an expected
sense better than the usual one minus
one over e
there is a talk about multi-scale and
tropic regularization which uh it has
achieved state-of-the-art uh competitive
ratio but uh does this by way of a a
very a novel embedding method um very
different from previous ones used for
metrical task systems so it has some
some
future possibilities as well
uh
there is a there's a paper about smooth
analysis of polytope diameter uh where
it uses distinct analysis methods
involving uh the spectral methods
involving the spectrum of the of a
certain hat the associated intestine
that also has results about integer
polytopes and uh generalizes the
diameter to question to about almost
diameter so between many pairs of
vertices i believe and the final talk of
the session is about uh equi relating to
distinct online selection problems for
metroid's the the metroid secretary
problem and the contention resolution
problem
and it it completes the work of showing
that they are equivalent
so our our first talk is the on prefix
discrepancy i i hope our speaker is here
yeah i'm giving a thought so
okay please share your screen and then
go ahead
i think you have to stop sharing
oh my apologies okay
um
okay give me one second
okay
i think even not maximized it's it's
it's perfectly beautiful so
uh
yeah i just wanted to get clay
but uh i'm not sure how to get rid of
this okay yeah here we go it's fine
oh
okay
all right uh
so hello everyone uh this talk will be
about discrepancy theory
uh i'm makran and this is a joint work
with nikhil mansell healthy engineering
and science segment
so main problem that we will be looking
at this talk is uh what's called the
vector balancing problem
uh so let me introduce this now
uh here you are given vectors v one
through v t
so two vector t vectors uh these are d
dimensional vectors and they all have
euclidean norm at most one
and our goal is to balance these vectors
in some way
so one of the most popular uh questions
about vector balancing is the so-called
kombucha conjecture
uh which says the following that you can
always assign signs to these vectors
either plus or minus
such that when you looked at the vector
that is the signed sum of all these
vectors
meaning that you sum these vectors by
assigning the corresponding sign
then each coordinate of the final sign
some vector is
at most a constant
so the infinity norm of this final
vector is a constant
so
this is a very strong conjecture in
discrepancy theory
it implies other popular conjectures
like the back theater conjectures
and other important results like
spencer's theorem
and this has been a long-standing open
problem and the best
bond we know for this problem
is due to banashik
who gave a bound of square root log d
plus square root of log t whereas d is
the dimension and t is the number of
vectors
so they're still
closest i mean this is close to the
constant bond but still
not exactly constant because it depends
on the dimension and the number of
vectors
and this is the best we know of
and this relies on some very nice convex
geometric uh methods uh
this result
so this is the cognition conjecture
this talk will be concerned with a
variant of this problem that i will call
the prefix discrepancy problem
so in the komlosh conjecture we only
looked at the final sign sum but here we
care about all prefixes also
so if we stop at any point
and look at all the
the sign some of the vectors until that
point and we want to minimize the
infinity norm of all such vectors as
well
so this is a prefix discrepancy problem
the best bound for this problem is the
same as for the congress conjecture it's
due to banash check square root log d
plus square root log t
so looking at the final sign sum or all
prefixes i mean so far it doesn't seem
to make a difference in the bound
and this is what we're going to explore
in this talk
and let me mention that this prefix
discrepancy problem this also is related
to another very classic problem in
discrepancy theory called the stymies
problem
which has various applications in
integer programming and approximation
algorithms
so in this talk we'll look at you know
what kind of structure does prefix
discrepancy imposes on our bounds and
you know
what sort of uh problems come because of
it
here are some motivating questions for
the talk
first one can ask you know is monastics
found optimal for the prefix discrepancy
problem if you look at all prefixes here
is the square root log b or square block
t necessary
because cone rush conjecture says that
for the final sum is the bound is a
constant
secondly i mean you can view the
prefixes of one through three as just
the prefixes of the path
so you consider graph which is just the
path graph on t vertices and prefix
discrepancy problem you're looking at
the prefixes of one of this path
but what if we consider prefixes of a
general tree or a general dag
so now you want to uh minimize the
description see over all with all such
constraints as well
uh
i mean
how does this compare to banana
shakespeare
and lastly i mean one can study
the setting when the discrepancy
constraints are coming from arbitrary
set system as not just prefixes of a
graph or a tree
and we call this problem the
combinatorial discrepancy problem
so
these are the questions that we look at
in this work
and let me tell you what we prove about
we can say about these questions
so firstly for uh
the question about whether bananas bound
is optimal for prefix discrepancy
problem
we show that this is not the case in a
smooth analysis setting
so if you perturb these vectors by
adding a small amount of noise and the
noise model we can consider
can be
pretty general so it covers a lot of
different types of noises
all we need is that the covariance
matrix has a
sufficiently
large eigenvalue which is one over
polynomial in the dimension
uh and in this case you can improve
banana six bound by uh exponential
factor in and the parameter t
so the bound becomes root log log t in
this parameter with high probability
so the number of vectors is exponential
even
we get the same bound
uh as this is found here
and uh
i mean let me also mention that this
bound is uh in the smooth setting but
that we prove
is also tied assuming that this bound is
tight in the worst case
so if anastasia's mounted tyson in the
worst case then even for a random
completely random instance our bond
cannot be improved for prefix
discrepancy
so this is the first result
and what if we consider prefixes of a
tree or attack i mean how does the
situation change
so in this case if you look at prefixes
of a tree
uh we can still show that monastics
bound still hold in this setting
uh
root log t plus root log t
but in this setting it cannot be
improved
and more generally if you consider any
dag and you have to compare the
discrepancy with respect to another
parameter called the hereditary
discrepancy
which i'm not going to define here but
the discrepancy
with respect to any prefixes of a dag
can be bounded in terms of the heavy
duty discrepancy
of the set systems times this root log t
d plus root log t factor
and for
a tree or the line
this factor heritable discrepancy is
always bounded by constant
so uh we recover manashi's bound here
and as i mentioned uh
for a tree or a dag this upper bound is
tied even for a random instance
this boundary is always achieved so this
setting differs from the setting of a
path or a line
which is quite interesting
and lastly if you look at any arbitrary
set system
in this case the discrepancy we can show
that discrepancy is still bounded by the
in terms of the heritage discrepancy of
the underlying set system
then some polylog factors
but here the polylog factor
also depends on the size of the set
system which can be pretty large
so these are our results
and let me just conclude with some open
problems
that follow from this line of work
the first question is you know one can
wonder about a strong version of
kombucha conjecture which asks whether
you know there always exists sign so
that all prefixes have constant
discrepancy
as far as we know this could be true uh
and this implies the convolutional
lecture but maybe it's easier to prove
lower bounds for for this problem
because you it's a strictly harder
problem
uh secondly you know combo short
bacterial conjectures are long-standing
open problems in the field
and to make progress on them
recently a lot of work has gone into
studying random instances for these
conjectures
but one can also try to understand what
happens in a smooth analysis setting do
these conjectures hold in some
reasonable noise model or not
and that also tells you something about
the lower bound instances for these
problems
it says that the if the conjecture holds
in the smooth setting
then such instant instances must be
quite rigid because it does not hold for
if you allow a tiny bit of noise in the
model
uh so this is another very interesting
direction uh to pursue
and lastly uh
the third question is sort of related to
this combinatorial discrepancy problem
where our bounds are polylog factors and
also depend on the cardinality of the
set system
and one can wonder if we can assume
achieve bounds similar to what we
achieve for dags here for a general set
system
and lastly
there is always a very interesting
question of making these rules
algorithmic so let me mention that we
can essentially make all our results
algorithmic if we
lose an extra log d or log d factor
but achieving the optimal bound with an
algorithm uh it remains a very
interesting problem as well
so uh i will stop here thank you very
much
uh if there are any questions i'll be
happy to answer them
yeah thanks very much
yeah so any any questions from the uh
the panelists or i guess attendees would
raise their hands and uh and
we would allow them to to speak
okay i guess we'll uh we'll move on
thanks very much um
uh uh now you wanna you wanna show your
screen yeah sure
can you see the slides
yeah
okay um
so uh hello everyone my name is junior
i'm a phd student at stanford university
today i'm going to tell you about budget
smooth analysis of modular maximization
this is joint work with my advisor
available instead
let me introduce a problem set up using
a motivating application
suppose we are getting our friends to
vote but we are so busy so we only have
time to remind the care of our friends
to vote
and they'll remind their friends to vote
and their friends and so on
this problem is called influence
diffusion
and the objective can be modeled as a
monotonous modular function
here motor means more of your friends
you remind more people will vote in the
end
the module means
the same person cannot vote twice even
if two of their friends remind them
the modular functions have a lot of
applications in e-comm and machine
learning
specifically
the model maximization problem asks us
to choose an optimal subset
of k elements that maximizes the sub
modular function
the cardinality constraint k is
sometimes also called a budget
this problem is solved decades ago
specifically there is a greedy algorithm
that achieves one minus one re
approximation ratio and there is a
matching hardness result
that says
in order it is impossible to beat 1
minus 1 over e using efficient
algorithms
more recent research focuses on
designing streaming parallel robust or
faster algorithms that also get a 1
minus 1 over e approximation
so what about the missing one over e
the point is 1 minus 1 over e is just a
worst case guarantee and in practice
people observe greedy does much better
how much better the answer depends on
the application or the instance
however there is a recent work that
shows on many realistic instances really
achieves 80 to 99 approximation ratio
therefore a very nice open problem in
this area is why greedy does better in
practice and what makes practical
instances easier
can we do even better than greedy in
practice
we are not the first people who study
these questions
there are many previous work try to
model beyond worst case modular
functions
however
these proposals they suffer from two
kinds of issues
either they are too strong and
intractable to verify in practice
or they are too weak
so they cannot beat 1 minus 1 over e
so in summary we have a lot of great
ideas but we still don't know what is a
nice modular function
therefore we are we have a beyond worst
case dilemma on the one hand we want
performance we want to explain the
missing one over e or at least a
fraction of it
on the other hand we want robustness we
want our model to apply widely to
practical instances and we want the
assumption to be easy to verify in
practice
our approach to resolve this dilemma is
starting from an overlooked object
recall that our um
some model maximization problem has two
objects
the function f and the budget k
so our observation is that
independent of modeling beyond worst
case modular functions we can also model
every case behavior
of the budget
and this approach is motivated by both
practice and theory
and it allows us to get both performance
and robustness
so in the longer
video i give more detailed explanation
and examples of this but now
let me just
jump right into the model for the
interest of time
so our model is called budget smooth
analysis
we first fix a budget distribution for
example the budget distribution of the
2000 demo 2020 democrats candidates
campaign
then the adversary picks a single worst
case module function
arguably all the candidates are
optimizing roughly the same function
for example they might be doing
influence maximization over the same
social network
like facebook or youtube
but as you can see they have very
different budgets
then we sample a random budget from the
distribution
and we run the algorithm on the instance
given by the function f and the budget
cap
our analysis show shows greedy
guarantees that average
candidates campaign was 67 optimal
let me do this one more time but a bit
more formally
we first fix a budget distribution d
then adversary picks a single worst case
module function f
then we sample a random budget k from
the distribution
and run the algorithm on the instance of
fnk
the performance measure is the expected
approximation ratio
where the expectation is taken over the
budget distribution
and we show greedy guarantees every
candidate's campaign was 67 percent
optimal
by simple markov argument this shows
most candidates should do better than
one minus one over e
we call our desired rata we want
robustness our model makes no assumption
on functions and the noise model is
arguably very simple
and in fact in practice we can simply
verify the assumption about a budget
distribution
by just calculating the empirical
distribution of the budgets
what about performance
we explained the four percent out of
missing 37 percent
and our model requires a larger
predication
so this is good but there is room for
future work for example one can combine
our budget smooth analysis model with
the model that makes assumption about
functions to get even better
approximation ratio
now let me state our main results
first
we show that in the budget smooth
analysis model greedy algorithm is still
optimal for every budget distribution
this result extends to other greedy type
algorithms in map reduce and parallel
settings
we find this result quite surprising
because greedy algorithm is independent
of budget
in the other words greedy automatically
adjusts itself according to the budget
distribution in an optimal way
besides we derive a simple but
non-convex program that computes
expected approximation ratio in the
budget smooth analysis model
and we observe better than 1 minus 1
over e approximation by solving this
problem for many realistic budget
distributions
finally we prove a robust hardness
result
that says no budget distribution allows
better than 90 approximation in
expectation
so
finally i have another i want to give
another takeaway
that is um i i believe budget smooth
analysis is interesting and should be
applied to other budget-constrained
optimization problems
because i think budget smooth analysis
provides attractable beyond the worst
case performance test for the worst case
optimal algorithms
if the worst case
optimal algorithm passes the test namely
it is still optimal in the budget smooth
analysis model
then this gives
rigorous evidence that the algorithm
[Music]
probably has been has good average case
performance if the if the algorithm
fails the test
then by designing budget smooth analysis
by the smallest optimal algorithm
we might find better worst case optimal
algorithm that performs better in
practice
so in the uploaded video i give
more explanation and examples
of of this point
so here for the interest of time
let me just
stop here and i'm happy to take
questions
thanks
thank you
so are there any questions
um hi i have a question
i was
i was wondering
um
what sort of aspects of a distribution
make it
uh more
you know make it possible to achieve a
better approximation ratio so is it like
high variance distributions or what sort
of
heuristics yes
that's a very good question so
in general we find of course uh
if your distribution is more spread that
is supported on a wide range then you
could expect a
better approximation ratio in
expectation
for example
if you consider like exponential
distribution on a larger range of
budgets
then that could give you
significantly better than one minus one
movie approximation ratio
okay thanks
uh anyone else
so so i guess a natural question is uh
the possibility of a high probability
bound or some something more than
average case with respect to the budget
distribution
yeah
so
yeah so first just uh if you have
expectation then by mark of inequality
you know you can say something
uh with high variability with words
um
approximation ratio
so yeah
okay
so thanks very much i guess
we'll go on to
the next talk
um
[Music]
can you hear me
okay
yeah
so hi everyone i'm farzan and today i'm
going to talk about the magical task
systems problem
on general metric spaces and this is
based on the joint work with james lee
so first let me define the problem to
you so imagine you're given a magic
space in this case a path metric
and that we're standing at some point in
symmetry
and over time
a monster appears at some locations in
this metric and if it if it appears at
the location that we're standing on we
have to make a move either to the left
or to the right
otherwise we can stay on it
and you would be paying a cost of the
total distance that you have traveled
and the crucial thing is that you have
to make decision these decisions online
without knowing what
what will happen in the future
and the goal is to remain competitive
with respect to
an optimal offline algorithm that knows
the future
so more precisely we say than that an
online algorithm is alpha competitive if
for any fixed input sequence
the cost that this algorithm pays
is upper bounded by alpha times the cost
of the off up to some additive constant
vectors
and this constant factor can depend on
the metric but it cannot depend on the
time t that we're measuring onto
so it's not hard to see that if we
if the algorithm is only allowed to make
deterministic choices that is then it
cannot do better than omega and
competitiveness but uh
in a random case we can do much better
we can get it down to quality log n so
what do i mean by that
uh we say that a randomizer online
algorithm is alpha competitive if it's
expected class is upper bounded by alpha
times it costs a lot
uh
so let me define
this problem in the more general setting
so we're given the matrix a metric x and
dx and our time and sequence of cost
vectors ct
arrive over time and these vectors are
non-negative
and we must respond to
the ct with a possibly random xt in x
and uh we would be paying a total cost
of uh as someone over these movement
costs which is what i
suggested earlier and
as well as the service costs which at
time t would be the entry of this vector
c t at the point x t which we are
playing
and uh
equivalently we can define this problem
as if the algorithm is
playing deterministically but it's it's
allowed to play fractionally so it's
allowed to choose some point mu t in the
probability simplex over
the points of this metric x
and then the service class can be
written as this inner product of ct and
mu t
and the movement cost uh can be
rephrased as uh
this earth mover distance between mu t
minus one and ut
and the goal is to minimize this
and this problem has been introduced by
in 92 by the work of boarding
lionel and sex
and is one of the
central open problems in the area of
online algorithms
so it is conjectured that we should be
able to obtain a
login combinative algorithm for
any metric space and in fact for some
special families of metrics and
a log in bound both as an upper bound as
the lower bound has been obtained but
for general negative spaces
after a long line of work the best upper
bound that we know is log squared of n
and the best lower bound is log n or log
log n
so our focus in this stock would be on
the side of upper bounds uh
so let's see how these upper bounds are
obtained uh first let's focus on a
rather simpler metric
which is the weighted stars
so uh this metric is essentially
the shortest path metric between
the leaves of a weighted star graph
so here the distance in and this v1 and
v2 is w1 plus w2
and uh so in response to
cost vector ct
what kind of makes sense is that we have
we should kind of reduce the amount of
mass that we're playing at points that
we're seeing more cost at
but when we do that we have to
redistribute this mass to the other
points in the metric otherwise we'll
we're leaving this uh probabilities in
place
so
so the idea is to just project this mu t
minus eta times ct back to
the
convex set kx and this eta is just some
learning rate uh
which which would be constant over the
one of the algorithm
and the main question is how do we use
three distribution or this projection
uh
the first case might be to do this with
euclidean uh
distance and then would correspond to
doing a project at gradient descent
but it turns out that this wouldn't work
but if instead we were doing a this
projection
with the
pigment divergence of some regularizer
phi
then its algorithm would correspond to
mere descent which is well studied in
the study of convex
optimization
and turns out that we could get a
login competitive algorithm
so
of course it would depend on
what phi we need to choose
and it turns out that if you choose phi
to be this uh
weighted entropy function uh
or something similar to that you would
obtain a logging competitive algorithm
so the main crucial thing about this uh
mirror descent framework is that it it
kind of allows us to
bound the service cost of our algorithm
and with the
total cost of the optimal algorithm in a
very convenient way and in the
especially in the early work on this
problem
this has been kind of the hardest part
of
the analysis
but
now we kind of get this uh part for free
and but
the catch is that we don't necessarily
have a bound on our movement cost
and for that we have to take a more uh
clever regular phi
uh
so let's switch to a more general family
of metrics uh which are called
hierarchically separated trees or hscs
for sure
so these metrics are
just
the shortest path metrics on the leaves
of a
rooted uh weighted
tree
in which the weight of the edges goes
down go down geometrically along root
leaf passes
and because of this geometric decay we
can see that the
the length of the shortest path between
two points is essentially dominated by
the largest
edge in that path
and the interesting fact about hsc's is
that up to a factor of login they can
essentially
approximate all metrics so
i'm not going to
explain this formally but
but the main takeaway is that if we can
get a
get an alpha competitive algorithm for
hst matrix it will automatically imply
that there is an alpha times login
competitive algorithm for any major
and in fact that's how
the case of general metrics was handled
in the
prior work in the work of bubeck
cohen v and lee in the work of closer
and lee
what they did was they first provided a
login competitive algorithm for
uh
mts and hscs and then it would imply
that
there's a log n squared competitive
algorithm for all metrics
uh
and this was done via mere descent as
you might have guessed
so um
instead of uh doing mere descent on
directly on the probability simplex over
the points of the metric
we have to do it on a sort of lift of
this uh probability simplex and more
precisely we would be
representing this probability this re
distribution
as a unit flow from uh the root of the
street with the set of its leaves
and then if you define the regularizer
as a
sort of multi-scale
conditional entropy
function then it turns out that we get a
logging competitive algorithm
but uh
but as i mentioned earlier the
conjecture is that the correct path for
this problem is login and it seems that
this extra login factor that that we're
paying because of this reduction is
unnecessary
and it was asked by we'll write whether
we can get rid of this reduction at
least and and can we at least get the
same poly logarithmic bonds that as
before but directly while they're
directly using mere descent
uh two minutes two minutes yeah sure two
minutes okay
thanks and uh
our main result is to
show that uh we can actually do this uh
we show that
essentially we can
run
mere descent and a dag constructed on
top of these hst matrix
sorry
given metric
and obtain a login squared competitive
algorithm
so i'm not going to get into the details
of that but essentially given a metric
we construct a dag on top of it and
define a regularizer similar to what we
had for hscs
and we showed that uh
this algorithm would be log n squared
combinative as long as some properties
are satisfied
uh for this stack
and uh
as for open problems so we haven't uh
essentially improve the upper bound of
this problem but
we have kind of made the conceptual
progress in this problem
and
i think
it is possible to build up any ideas to
improve improve on the login squared
bound
and this is still open even for the path
metric
and the lower bound is also for
a log log n factor far from the
conjectured panel
and if we can prove a lower one for hsc
matrix it would imply a lot of alcohol
so yeah that's it
okay thanks very much
maybe a quick question
okay when we go on to uh to the next
talk thank you thanks very much
all right um
hello everyone
looks good
good great
um
okay so this talk is on a spectral
approach to polytope diameter so first
i'm just going to give a brief history
of the problem then describe the uh
the results from the spectrograph theory
that we use and then go into how to
apply those results in the context of
this context geometry problem
um
so in this talk a polytope uh all
applied tells me to discuss will be
living in d dimensions that's sort of
the ambient space and all poly types
will have m constraints
um and
given a polytope we define a point on
the on the boundary of the polytube via
vertex if d of the constraints are tight
and similarly a line segment is an edge
if d minus one constraints are tight
now the vertices and edges of a polytope
uh correspond very naturally to the
vertices and edges of an associated
connected graph
and drawn in orange here is an example
for the cube the vertices and edges form
a graph here
the question that we ask is what is the
diameter of this graph
this is motivated by linear programming
where a lot of linear programming
algorithms work by picking a vertex of
the polygon of some polytope of feasible
solutions then following this graph or
following some path longest graph to an
optimal vertex for some definition of
optimal optimum
and it would be nice to know that all
these paths are short
um
so a trivial bound is just an upper
bound of the total number of vertices
which is m choose d
but this is exponential and d it's not
desirable at all
so the goal is to do much better and
indeed
that's what this is towards
so an old conjecture from the 1950s is
that the diameter of this graph is upper
bounded by m minus d so m is the number
of constraints and d is the ambient
dimension
and there are two results that i first
want to highlight about this uh the
first is that it's upper bounded by m
minus t to the log d so it's still far
away away from the conjecture
and um the second result is actually
disproving the specific curse conjecture
so there's a construction due to santos
that shows the diameter is actually at
least m for a certain class of polytopes
so the updated conjecture that we are
now working towards is is the diameter
bounded just by some polynomial in m and
d so it's not going to be m minus b but
is it some polynomial
now this this has proven to be quite
difficult to prove so instead we have
focused and the literature has focused
on a slightly easier variant which
allows which allows us one additional
parameter which is the max determinant
of any sub matrix of the constraint
matrix
so in this setting we instead take the
polytope the constraint matrix to have
all integer entries and oh we let delta
be the max determinant
and we allow the diameter to depend a
polynomial in md and delta
so the first result is that if delta is
one i.e this matrix is unimodular then
the hersch conjecture is true that it is
a polynomial energy
and in general
for for a general delta the bound uh
that's known previous to this work is as
d cubed delta squared um the problem of
course is that delta could be
exponential in um
uh
in d and m so this does not prove the
curves projection um
has this actually a parameter there
so now our result improves this
or in some setting of these parameters
and proves it to the case of d squared
delta squared log m delta
so the result from spectrograph theory
is a conversion from a spectral gap of a
generalized adjacency matrix into a
diameter
so if you take an adjacency matrix but
then let all the non-zero entries be
anything or any positive value as
opposed to one then you get in a
generalized jdc matrix and for
generalized adjacency matrices
a spectral gap turns into a bound on the
diameter so in green i have a picture of
what the eigenvalues might look like so
if you have all the eigenvalues in
between the interval minus one to one
but then one eigenvalue the top one
separated away from the rest by gamma
you can turn this into a boundary
diameter and the proof is pretty
straightforward you just apply degree
khmership polynomial to this matrix s
then the non-zero entries of that matrix
uh will correspond to the existence of
paths of length at most k
but when you apply this polynomial it
blows up the rank 1 matrix corresponding
to the top eigenvalue and suppresses the
rest so if the degree is high enough
this this matrix
t of s will be approximately rank 1 and
all the entries will be positive
so the two key parameters in this result
are
the value of the smallest entry in the
corresponding eigenvector um because in
that rank one matrix you know the
entries to be positive so you need all
the entries in the eigenvector to be
positive and also the size of the gap we
want the size of the gap to spectral
have to be large so those are the two
key parameters that we need to do let me
just uh zoom past the proof of the
statement that sort of explained in
words
um
so we first though need to define what
the generalized adjacency matrix we use
is going to be so we need to construct
what what adjacency matrix the adjacency
matrix is
and to do that we need to introduce this
notion of a polar of a polygon so if
you're given a polytope you can think
about the
constraints as a collection of vectors
um
thus for the rows of a now the polar of
the polytope is simply the convex hull
of those constrained vectors uh
appropriately normalized
now the nice thing about uh the polar of
a polytope is that the facets of an
original correspond to vertices and the
vertices of the original correspond to
facets so here i have a little example
of a cube corresponding to an octahedron
so these these six faces of the cube
become the six vertices of the
octahedron and the eight vertices of the
queue become the eight facets of the
octahedra
and now the graph
which was formerly the edge vertex graph
the original polytope corresponds to the
facet incidence graph of the polar the
facets are now our nodes and the edges
connecting nodes are the intersections
between two adjacent facets
so
the goal is to found the diameter of the
facet incident graph of the polar
polytune
so the key idea is to note that the
polar polytope itself because it's a
polytope it can be naturally written as
a condex hall in terms of the problem
description but it can also be written
as mx less than c for some other
constraint matrix m
in vector c
and the key idea here is to consider
this the volume of this polytope as a
function of those slack variables the c
vectors so m x less than c as a function
of c what is the volume of the polytope
our first claim is that this passion the
hessian of this volume function is a
generalized adjacency matrix
and the second claim is that it has
exactly one positive eigenvalue
so first let's look at the first claim
that it's a generalized adjacency matrix
uh we'll sort of just do a proof by
picture
the partial derivative of the volume
with respect to one of the slack
variables is just the volume of the
corresponding facet
and to see that you can see in this
diagram on the side the orange line is
the volume of the new facet after uh i
prefer is the
the difference between the blue and
parallel blue and orange lines is the
change in the volume as i perturb c sub
i by a small amount
so it's just the volume of that facet
and now the second derivative i want to
know how quickly does the or what's the
rate at which the volume of one facet
changes as they change the slack
variable corresponding to a different
facet
um and
you can see that that value will only be
non-zero if these facets intersect if
the facet and if i and fj don't
intersect then changing c sub j has no
effect on the volume of f phi and vice
versa so only when these two things
intersect we get a non-zero value which
is exactly what we need in order for
this to be an adjacency matrix
okay
so the second claim that it has exactly
one positive eigenvalue this comes from
noting the nature of the diagonal
entries oh sorry excuse me uh
this comes from noting that the log of
of the hessian or sorry the log of the
volume is a concave function this is not
a trivia this is not a trivial fact to
see um but it's it's a prior result
that's known
um and it's true for general and it's
true as a fact of general log concave
functions uh their hessians um have
exactly one positive eigenvalue
um so we use a slot concavity
result
okay so
simply saying that one of the
eigenvalues is positive is not enough
for our result we need to show that
actually there's a spectral gap right
that that one eigenvalue is far away
from the other eigenvalues
and to to show that we notice the
relationship between the hessian in a
particular laplacian
so it turns out that the diagonal
entries of this hessian um are
are almost like a laplacian except they
are all too small in order for uh
the hessian to be a laplacian so in
other words we can write the hessian as
minus the laplacian plus a strictly
positive matrix
and that is what allows us to um get a
spectral gap so multiply each side by d
to the one-half
then the left-hand side has exactly one
positive eigenvalue just by sylvester's
inertial line
and the right-hand side is a negative
semi-definite matrix plus the identity
uh so we know that this matrix has a
spectral gap of at least one
so it's not just that has one positive
eigenvalue we know that it's it's far
away from the other eigenvalues so that
leaves one away
okay so
we also know what the eigenvector is uh
the corresponding eigenvector is just
the square root of all the diagonal
entries corresponding to d
and we we can shift all these
eigenvalues up so some of these
eigenvalues might be very negative but
you shift them all up and do an
appropriate
linear combination of this matrix with
the identity and you wind up with
a matrix which is exactly the one we
want in the setting of our theorem where
all the eigenvalues are between -1
except for one which is gamma
and just using a little bit of
trigonometry you can show that this that
this gamma is the square of the sine of
the smallest angle between any of these
two factors
and that sort of then just directly
corresponds to
the results in the paper using that um
uh using a relationship between the max
debt of the sub matrices and the angle
gives the stated result
um so the last thing uh okay
so this is a summary of the of the main
steps
now the result from smooth analysis i
don't have time to go into but you can
check the paper essentially shows that
if you do a small perturbation of this
polytope let me go back slide a small
perturbation of this polytope then this
theta the angle between facets becomes
good for most of pairs of facets
so we're able to show that um in the
smooth setting uh
we remove the dependence on delta
squared and we show that there exists a
large component in other words a sub
graph of at least 99 of the vertices of
the original graph which has polynomial
diameter
um but of course we're not able to
extend that to the entire graph it's
just for a large component
um
okay so that is the result um and you
know some open questions are just
essentially can we improve any of the
steps in this in this work
and uh that's it if there's any
questions i'm happy to answer them
so do we have any questions
uh just very quick
uh we'll hold off then i guess and uh
and go to the last talk of this session
uh
all right
can you see my slides
yes
all right
can everybody hear me okay
i i can't
excellent all right so uh my name is
shad i'm going to tell you about how the
matrix secretary problem is equivalent
to contention resolution
so my main result is the following i
show that two statements are equivalent
the first one is the matrix secretary
conjecture which says that there's a
constant competitive algorithm
for the majority secretary problem
the second statement concerns contention
resolution on metroids and it says that
contention resolution there is
approximately as powerful in the random
order model as it is in the offline
model and this should hold for all
correlated distributions not just for
product distributions
so uh why is this interesting um let me
try and convince you that it's useful to
know this um first it tells us that the
matrix secretary problem even though it
features these adversarial weights is
actually equivalent to a natural
stochastic problem in particular the
contention resolution problem
it also suggests that um
online contention resolution in the
presence of positive correlation is
actually the core challenge of major
secretary because the second bullet is
known for product distributions and also
for negatively correlated distributions
for a suitable definition
and this connection to contention
resolution hopefully opens the door for
a lot of the recent progress on
contention resolution to be applied to
the matrix secretary conjecture
and finally
this tells us that the hard part of the
matrix secretary problem even though the
problem features these
cardinal weights the hard part only uses
ordinal information about those waves
uh so let me rephrase the second bullet
in a form that's a little bit more
convenient
so i say that every metroid admits what
i call a universal random order
contention resolution scheme
what do i mean by universal let me tell
you first i'm going to say a
distribution over subsets of the
elements of the metroid is alpha
uncontentious if it allows alpha
balanced contention resolution offline
so this is where you select each active
element with probability alpha times the
probability that it shows up
okay
uh and i say a contention resolution
scheme is universal if whenever you give
it a alpha balance an alpha
uncontentious distribution it achieves a
c times alpha balance so it matches the
best possible offline up to a
universal constant factor of c okay
so um this is another restatement of the
previous form of the statement
and it turns out that i need i only need
even a weaker form of that uh second
bullet uh i only require you to do uh
well for a single uh fixed alpha so here
i say there exists an alpha and a beta
such that every matrix emits a beta
alpha universal random order contention
resolution scheme which says that you
achieve a beta balance for every alpha
uncontentious distribution and this
should hold only for a single alpha so
what happens is that the matrix
secretary conjecture implies the strong
form of content of universal contention
resolution in the second bullet the sec
the strong form obviously implies the
weak form and then all you need is the
weak form to establish the uh metroid
secretary conjecture
so um this result builds on my previous
work and i call from two years ago there
i proved uh the forward direction which
is the matrix secretary conjecture
implies universal contention resolution
um and there i proved a weak uh form a
weak converse uh which says that beta
alpha universal random order contention
resolution in a restrictive model of
contention resolution which may or may
not be realistic implies the matrix
secretary conjecture so this is a weak
converse uh here
so in this paper i remove the
restriction and basically strengthen the
second direction to prove full
equivalent of the
full equivalence of these three
statements
so i'm going to note that this result is
information theoretic and i don't get
into whether or not any of these
reductions can be made computationally
efficient
so this is the picture this is the
picture of the reductions so i want you
to think of these arrows in the
algorithmic sense so the error from the
top to the bottom says you use an
algorithm for major secretary to solve
universal contention resolution so this
direction was the easier direction it
was shown in my i called paper from two
years ago and uses the observation that
matrix secretary just essentially solves
a dual of contention resolution so in
this paper i proved the opposite i use
the universal contention resolution
scheme in the random order model to
prove the matrix secondary conjecture
so um
so the approach looks somewhat familiar
uh for anybody who's worked on matrix
secretary algorithms first you sample
roughly half the elements as they show
up online and then you
try and resolve contention for the
improving elements and those are the
elements that improve the offline
optimum on the sample so you try and
select subset of those and you want to
select each of them with constant
probability that's what contention
resolution would guarantee
so um here's a first step at that
so from my previous paper we know that
improving elements even though they
feature positive correlation are
actually uncontentious again in the
offline sense
and uh it's easy to see that they're
worth a constant fraction of the optimum
value so if you apply universal
contention resolution to the improving
elements uh you should you should be
able to recover a uh constant fraction
of the optimum value
but there's a major problem with this
approach um
and it's the following in contention
resolution we require the distribution
of uh inputs that is given up front it's
known a priori but here we don't know it
because the improving element
distribution depends on the unknown
adversarial weights
so this in this paper the first thing we
do is we solve this difficulty by first
reducing the matrix secretary problem uh
to the metroid profit secretary problem
um and the major profit secretary
problem is just the version of the
matrix secretary problem we are given
where the weights are drawn from a known
prior
and here i allow the prior to have
arbitrary correlation
and this reduction is pretty simple it's
just duality
um and now
this reduction buys us something when
the weight vector is stochastic now we
know the distribution of weight so
therefore we know the distribution of
improving elements and we can initialize
a contention resolution scheme with that
distribution and apply the same approach
i outlined earlier
so this seems like it solved the problem
we had before but unfortunately
introduces another problem when the
weights are uh stochastic they're random
and they're correlated um
now uh contention resolution no longer
guarantees an approximation factor
because even though you might select
each improving element with constant
probability um the
the selection events may be imbalanced
with respect to the possible weights the
element may have so maybe you select an
element half the time but you only
select it when its weight is small
rather than its weight it's large so you
can't guarantee that you recover a
constant fraction of the contribution of
the weights
um so um we show that this problem
actually is a real problem there's
examples where this shows up um so we
have to kind of do something here to
solve this problem we introduced um so
what i do is i basically define a
stronger form of contention resolution
called labeled contention resolution
where i label each element with its
weight and i require a stronger notion
of balance with respect to element label
pairs
so i didn't really do anything
interesting here yet basically i just
kicked the can down the road i defined a
more difficult problem a more difficult
version of contention resolution and
asked you to solve that
but it
turns out that this is the right
definition
so finally in the last step i reduced
label to unlabeled contention resolution
online so uh this is easy to see how
that this is possible in the offline
setting because you can cheat because
you can treat each element label pair as
a parallel copy of the element but it
turns out this is highly non-trivial
online and we
show that nevertheless you can do it um
in the random order model um and then
and this is where a lot of the technical
work in the paper goes
and for more detail i refer you to the
paper and the longer talk
so this is the picture we end up with
and we conclude that all these four
problems are equivalent up to constant
factors
so to conclude uh i showed that the
matrix secondary problem is equivalent
to online contention resolution in the
random order model for these
uncontentious distributions and this is
interesting because um
the contention resolution problem we get
is obviously stochastic in nature and
ordinal in nature
um now the contention resolution problem
we reduce to
is challenging because it features
positive correlation in the input set
however this positive correlation is not
arbitrary it seems somewhat benign in
particular in my original paper i have a
polyhedral characterization of
uncontentious distributions and
hopefully if we can use this
characterization to help in online
contention resolution then that might
help resolve the matrix secretary
conjecture
and that's all i have thanks
thanks very much uh i think i think
there might be a quick
[Music]
or not but i i think i think we'll uh
conclude there we're just about exactly
on top so
well thank thanks very much that's the
end of this session
you